I don't get it I'm confused
I thought I could place it down and just
put them together or something
or they need all the parts
and don't know where to find all of ours
maybe all the parts isn't here
it seems like I've shaked all the rooms
I think it's pointless just wander
around here for just circles I might as
well go up and shake some of the place
I'm just wasting time here it seems what
is this
I thought it was a drill
apparently not
okay I'm gonna head up back up if I can
find back up great suffered the lag oh
what's underneath
dude if someone's do it up there I would
have pissed my panties oh wait there's
other places to go
all right oh yeah
[ __ ] em no no we left so I shouldn't use
that apparently some Aleksandr
Brandenburg told someone to kidnap he
ordered someone to kidnap people through
this castle yeah yeah then fooled that
guy to kill a queue and killed him
and we found his loss notes before and
apparently they kidnapped like hundreds
of people to the castle which I'm never
returned before which is pretty creepy
I think I can hear someone yeah pretty
creepy
don't need to say that twice and here's
him
why is this
I think this is what I'm gonna blow up
or something
otherwise wouldn't be in nature
ramaa from Cape as I find a way to get
through alright we're gonna I'm gonna
try at least
guess that's what matters yeah
question
[Music]
I'm not scared just kidding my pastor
here come on let there be light
I need oil [ __ ] oh there's none of that
torch what is this
awesome we got old apartment oh that is
some monster [ __ ] oh there is oh god
every time I see like this my pants I
thought it was safe there was nothing
going on there for a while it's like he
always appears me please expect it
[ __ ]
it looks even more creepy now as well
their mom there
I'm not sure what I was supposed to do
let's put these together all right we
got our drill I really don't want to
continue playing
I am almost about to throw up I have
really really scared at the moment we're
gonna keep doing the one I'm doing
heartbeat
that's let's crouch and listen really
careful
as much I think you're a bro
this is not working out
is this down yeah this wrong way
oh god I thought I saw in there
you are alpha
man said darling in the darkness head is
pounding hands are shaking that's for
[ __ ] sure
Oh
the two with our chemistry
yes you are crying
it doesn't matter okay we got that one
and then the other one is over there
so this one said the secondary so I
guess we're gonna do that
nice and easy
I got a feeling he's gonna appear when I
do this
oh yeah the drill
we're cool you're not that bro
no brofist not today not [ __ ] today
okay bro nothing here just gonna grab my
grab my secondary
don't mind me you know doing anything at
all
wait dododo don't make me look there I
want to see if he's comes
cappen corner
so we got our explosive and I assume
we're gonna use that too
doot-doot don't sneak up on me how we
got that no not together
go ahead act the way we saw the monster
Keith salmon notice already
I am a [ __ ] you can leave that in
comments as much as you want I don't
give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this game is going
we're not gonna go up there
unfortunately
slight headache it's got better that's
right
stop crying you [ __ ] [ __ ] you get
the monster
got to remember where I came from
was it up the stairs yeah it was
I don't like running
I feel like that mother is gonna be up
here
I know
yeah just gonna shake my microphone with
it's nothing muta don't forget that I
would have feeling really stupid if my
microphone was muted no it's not
obviously you guys knew that
alright so it's in here
for us
I get the feeling I'm gonna blow this up
but I'm not sure we're gonna try
oh it was right don't start oh [ __ ]
I was supposed to like
there was something I had added
oh oh [ __ ] oh this kind of flower oh
[ __ ] I was thank the pro was then
inherit though
alright those words
glad we don't have a land yeah we do
have but it's so insignificant a lot of
toil let's just use it to you alright
puzzles all let's be neat
I am very low of health I should that
took me a lot of damage I thought it was
pretty far away
I really could use some oil right now
stop crying you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I hate it so much
even without the monster this game is
[ __ ] scary what the monster yes
[ __ ] creeps me out
I don't know about you guys but I've
always been he's always sneaks up on me
when I pick stuff up I don't like that
why not go into the darkness
get away from I can't see [ __ ]
by the way keeps you didn't know
they come from there
I don't waste these
so clear all right we're good sorry
whenever I'm so focused and scared
shitless I tend to forget to talk and
ramble or whatever
I am sorry about it but
I just get so into it
am I supposed to do here
lighting is excellent I'm saved given
that look at this looks [ __ ] amazing
I just want to [ __ ] it
my [ __ ] I know why I keep saying that
someone's kind of think I'm homosexual
reads to think whatever [ __ ] we want
I still don't know what my quest down
area is like what am I supposed to do
throw no [ __ ] bread at his face
others girlier yeah
no no no oh